Aaron Carter's exes are reacting to his
tragic death the loss came out of shock
to many he was only 34. Aaron's
ex-fiance Melanie Martin whom he shares
his 11 month old son Prince tearfully
mourned his death with a short clip on
tick tock
and fans were quick to offer their
condolences Melanie who had an on and
off again relationship with Aaron that
began in 2020 share this tribute on
Instagram hours later quote my baby I
can't breathe Hilary Duff also shared a
heartfelt message about her ex Aaron the
two briefly dated in their early teens
after he appeared on her hit Disney show
Lizzie McGuire oh my gosh guys where's
my tape recorder
I think I left it in Aaron's dressing
room
it's yours
Merry Christmas McGuire Hillary wrote
quote for Aaron I'm deeply sorry that
life was so hard for you and that you
had to struggle in front of the whole
world you had a charm that was
absolutely effervescent boy did my
teenage self love you deeply
you proud of her
another one of Aaron's former Flames
Brooke Hogan is honoring the late singer
too she said in part quote rest in peace
my sweet friend you deserve to be
somewhere better than this harsh world
I'm so grateful I got to know your
kindness silliness heart and talent you
are one of God's most special angels my
heart is broken
you're done I am yep no
that's Aaron with Lena Valentina who he
dated back in 2018 she's also speaking
out after his death sharing many
memories with her ex writing quote Aaron
I've mourned the loss of you a few days
before we broke up we both cried our
eyes out because your addiction won and
we both knew it for the last few years
now I knew that any day now I'd be
writing this she goes on to add that
Aaron is now in a better place than he's
been in the last couple years
[Music]
Aaron first sword to fame at the turn of
the Millennium with his music career I
love making music it's definitely my
happy place but in more recent years he
struggled with addiction and his mental
health are you still sober what kind of
Journey are you on now
I smoke weed I mean there I have anxiety
problems I take medication for anxiety
like I mean it's just it's just what it
is you know he developed a strained
relationship with his family including
his twin sister Angel and older brother
Nick
what I need is people to
understand that I'm human and I make
mistakes just like every other human in
this world despite being at odds with
each other the siblings shared emotional
tributes for their brother with these
throwback photos and when Aaron spoke
with E.T back in 2017 he explained his
and Nick's rocky relationship it's just
a brother thing yeah I mean it really
just is that like you know I love my
brother so much and he's influenced me
with like so much music he's eight years
older than me so
he's influenced me with you know a lot
of different cultures and music and what
he's picked up and so I mean
but besides that I mean there's always
going to be some sort of like
competition
[Music]